nos piden graficar la función f x igual
a 5 x menos 4 muy bien lo que vamos a
hacer es tomar una muestra de algunos
puntos del dominio vamos a ver cuánto
vale la función en esos puntos los vamos
a poner en un plano coordenada y después
vamos a conectar esos puntos para ver
cómo es la gráfica de la función hay
otras formas en las cuales se puede
graficar pero esta es la más sencilla
así que empecemos con eso observemos que
f está definida en todos los reales
cualquier real lo podemos multiplicar
por 5 y luego restarle 4 entonces déjame
pintar por aquí el eje x vamos a tratar
que este ya que es el eje x vale y por
acá voy a poner el eje che
el eje
y vamos a ponerle que che va a ser igual
a efe de x es decir ahorita vamos a
trazar la gráfica de la función fx y por
lo tanto la coordenada en que la
obtenemos metiendo el valor de x en la
función vale bueno vamos a tomar algunos
puntos del dominio para eso déjame hacer
una tabla y voy a tomar una tabla en
donde voy a poner aquí los valores de x
y acá los dejé que es f x que es
efe de x y bueno esta muestra de valores
no no va a ser muestra de valores muy
grandes son muy complicados queremos que
las cosas sean sencillas aquí podría
poner 20 millones pero sería muy latosos
después calcular
efe de 20 millones entonces déjame poner
aquí algunos números facilitos que van a
ir de menos 2 a 2 y van a brindar de uno
en uno vale bueno voy a comenzar con el
menos 2 aquí le voy a poner menos 2
muy bien si x es igual a menos 2 cuando
es bueno pues sería igual a fx y fx
sería 5 por x menos 4 pero x es menos 2
entonces nos quedaría 55 x menos 2 y
luego tenemos que restar 4 vale 5 x
menos dos es menos 10 menos cuatro es
menos 14 menos 14 va entonces uno de los
puntos en esta gráfica va a ser el menos
dos coma menos 14 déjame ponerle por
aquí este la escala para que sepamos
dónde están los puntos entonces déjame
tomar el color amarillo otra vez y voy a
poner por aquí pues a ver aquí va a
estar el -2 acá va a estar el menos 1 y
el 0 y el 1
y el 2 y para el eje g pues voy a poner
mira tenemos un -14 entonces deja de
poner por aquí el menos 5 por aquí el
menos 10 por aquel menos 15 menos cinco
menos diez menos quince y en los valores
positivos voy a poner por aquí el 5 por
aquel 10 muy bien ahora sí donde
quedaría este punto el menos dos menos
14 pues tenemos que tomar el punto que
está en menos 2 aquí y que está en menos
14 acá déjame bajar con una línea
punteada el menos 14 queda más o menos
como por acá entonces el punto que nos
interesa es este vale este es uno de los
puntos de la gráfica de la función el
menos 2 - 14 vamos a seguir con otros
puntos por ejemplo si aquí le pongo x
igual a menos 1 tenemos que hacer 5 x
menos 1 menos 45 x menos 1 es menos 5
menos 4 es igual a menos 9 vale entonces
ahora tenemos el punto menos uno coma
menos nueve por aquí que del -9 entonces
más o menos es este punto de acá vale
entonces este de acá es el menos uno
coma menos nueve muy bien ese es otro
punto en la gráfica df déjame tomar el
color morado para poner aquí el cero
entonces fx sería 5 por 0 5 por 0 - 4
que sería igual a 5 por 0 es cero y nos
queda menos 4 muy bien entonces el punto
ahora es el 0,4
- 4 este punto está sobre el eje y
vale entonces ahí ya tenemos 3 puntos y
este de acá le voy a poner que es el 0 -
4 muy bien vamos al color azul para ver
cuánto es este f 1
si x es un noche sf de uno que es 5 por
14 5 por 15 4 es igual a 1 entonces
tendríamos el punto 11 por aquí queda
más o menos el 1 entonces tendríamos
este punto de por acá vale este ya que
es el 1,1 y finalmente voy a ponerle 2
lo voy a poner con color verde entonces
el 2 nos da 5 por 2 menos 4 5 por 12 10
menos 46 y por lo tanto el punto el
último punto que nos interesa está más o
menos por acá
por acá hasta el 6 y entonces este punto
es el 2,6 muy bien entonces recuerda
hasta ahorita solo tenemos una muestra
de los valores de la función f en
algunos puntos de su dominio menos dos
menos 10 12
si queremos obtener la gráfica lo que
tenemos que hacer es unir estos puntos
entonces déjame unirlos con color blanco
y bueno si si tuviera un buen pulso
podemos ver que la idea general es que
esta gráfica es una línea va entonces
uniendo estos puntos y voy más o menos
uniendo estos puntos obtenemos una línea
y me quedo un poco chueco por mi pulso
pero bueno si tuviera reglas nos
quedaría una línea y por lo tanto la
gráfica de la función ahora sí la
gráfica de la función es esta línea
blanca y lo importante es que esta
gráfica ya tiene los puntos
correspondientes a todos los puntos del
dominio por ejemplo aquí nos comparamos
el 1.5 entonces el punto correspondiente
sería este si nos tomáramos el menos 0.5
entonces el punto correspondiente sería
este vale entonces lo importante es que
ya terminamos esto de aquí es la gráfica
de la función fx igual a 5 x menos 4